I watched him he was a little bit more
careful he was a little bit more held
back he was a little bit more like man
like how many more things is he dealing
with are you gonna pay for this guy's
legal fees are you going to pay for that
guy's legal fees are you going to pay
for this guy I remember when we started
the company and the company that sued us
they didn't just sue me I'm like if you
sue me I'm fine sue me the company my
wife I'll represent us but they ended up
soon a bunch of my guys so we had they
were trying to divide them against us we
almost didn't work out the first three
three six months legal fees have to pay
for this or pay for that you got to get
the money you got to get the so and then
if we're spending the money we're going
to go out of business at a company if my
guys are spending the money they're
saying it's all your fault Pat he's
going through that right now and there's
an element of no matter how tough you
are internally when you're by yourself
you're alone